this would be easier with a serrated
knife I think personally I love turkey I
only eat poultry so I only eat chicken
in Turkey I think drumstick is
definitely my favorite part of the
turkey and there's only two so that's
like you know it's a very competitive
thing I have zero cooking ability in
zero cooking experience I probably
learned how to boil water at a very old
age that's sort of embarrassing to admit
I just learned how to cut an onion the
other day when I was a freshman in
college so when I was like 18 I would
say I'm the person that kind of just
shows up on Thanksgiving I have never
carved a turkey in my entire life
oh I knew it
so you guys aren't actually going to
trap so he's a trap dammit I don't know
we got a nice okay so wait what if
what's our game plan here middle so have
you ever carved a turkey before no so
this is your first time yes and I'm a
part of it yes
angle it this is really awkward wait I
think it would work with left-handed
actually you're doing a great job thanks
you're doing a great job too but the
late gets in the weight
yeah the leg out of the way from oh yeah
cut the legs out I think you have a
little bit of turkey in your hair yeah
my gosh weighs attempt there string do
people usually do this that's an end
bondage no I don't think that's like
Disneyland should we turn to plate it
around so you could do the other side I
think you should do the other side I
don't think anyone will show up to our
Thanksgiving yes please great I feel
like he'd be like you guys did a great
job cuz look we did cut down to the
thigh had the legs be pushed down by the
wings ah it looks very different from
when we were doing
[Music]
the thighbone since his cooked well
should come off really easily it's nice
and tender
so you're gonna cut off the turkey
breast right here so we've got one
breast there that's max I think down
here yeah we didn't do that you can see
that it just comes open we have the
joint there and you can tear it or you
can find the joint and then you can just
kind of cut it what you want to do is
you actually want to cut against the
grain so if you see here now you've got
your beautifully carved turnout grass
it's pretty yeah now we're gonna go with
the drumstick what you want to do is you
want to find the joint and then all you
have to do is tear it then what you want
to do with the thigh you can just kind
of take it out and now you can flip it
over and cut the thigh meat so there you
go this looks so easy I thought we did a
pretty good job but it's become apparent
to me that we didn't know I mean I
feeling yeah we did this turkey carving
experience oh I definitely feel like I
can brag to my family now that I know
how to carve a turkey I definitely
didn't think there was as much to it as
there is our only strategy going into
the carving process was makin edible I
mean regardless of how its carved I'm
gonna eat it I do definitely have a
greater appreciation for Turkey Carver's
it is alright every single turkey that
I've seen carved even though I wasn't
really paying full attention didn't it
seem to look anything like how Vaughn
just showed us I don't think this has
inspired me to cook I think if anything
has deterred me I think I'll just stick
to the microwave
[Music]
anything with green like sage would be
really good here or rosemary we've got
cilantro
this is parsley
[Music]